[Musique]
moi chanter
en jamais
chanter pour gagner
vie non jamais chanté moi
ch jamais
[Musique]
chiici venu moi PL
chantter coucher sur le
dos dans le sable
[Musique]
chaud avec sa
doudou il fait son
dodo les deux bras en
croix comme le Roi des
rois
il préfère mon
île à son pays
[Musique]
froid pour passer
Noël et le jour de
l'an le touriste
blanc qui a un petit
argent moi
changé en
jamais changer en créole pays trop petit
pour gagner sa vie moi plus chanter au
non jamais chanter moi plus
chanter
en jamais
en moi partir
d'ici V moi PL
chanté
il me fait
courir après ses
planteurs il m'appelle
[Musique]
wonur
supérieur ça me met tout en
sour ça me fait mal au
cœur je suis pas son
chauffeur son
serviteur mais je suis de la
[Musique]
couleur de ma
clarinette je rêve au
sapin et aux
[Musique]
épinettes moi plus
chanter
enolleblie jamais
chaner en colle pays trop petit pour
gagner sa vie moi plus chanter au non
jamais chanter moi plus
chanter
enol plus jamais chanter
en moi partir d'ici au est venu moi plus
chanter